Her name is Miranda Priestly.
She is the most important woman in fashion in the world!
Emily is her first assistant...
...and we are looking for someone to be her second assistant!
I knew nothing about fashion and I didn't care!
So why did I suddenly want the job so much?
Maybe because a million other girls wanted it too.
This, Andy, is what you must wear.
People around here don't like your high-street look.
You're going to get fired if you're not careful.
Look, I'm really sorry about the weekend...
...but this job is going to open doors for me.
Yes, it is important.
Andrea, details and excuses, you know I don't like them.
I hope this doesn't happen again. That's all.
This was my life, my future.
I couldn't leave now.
Get me a glass of Pellegrino.